Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here, and
today I'm going to talk about the
most important thing in language
learning, and that is enjoyment.
Enjoyment is not only the goal of
language learning, enjoyment is how you
manage to succeed in language learning.
And I'm gonna talk about the five stages
of enjoyment because after all, as
we go through learning the language,
we are in different stages of either
we're beginning the language or we're
starting to get ahold of the language.
And there are different
kinds of enjoyment.
At least that's how I
experience language learning.
So when we begin the first stage, when
we're starting to discover the language,
at first it's all noise, but somehow as
if by magic, what was noise becomes words,
uh, you start to be able to read a little
bit even though you listen many, many
times and keep on missing the same parts
of what you're listening to and, and you
look up words, let's say on LingQ, and
you review them and you listen again.
And...
but it's exciting.
It's, it's that excitement of discovering
something new and, and that's in the
first stage of learning a language
that kind of maintains me because
so much of it is, is not meaning.
It's, it's unclear and, and it, it
just seems so strange at first, and
particularly when I was learning Persian
and Arabic with different writing
systems, it's so difficult at first.
However, there's that enjoyment,
that excitement of, of sort of,
I'm embarking on something new.
I'm gonna learn this.
What to me is an exotic language and, and
I find that initial period very enjoyable.
And so there is that first period of
enjoyment of discovering something new.
But then after a while, we get
tired of listening to the same
stuff over and over again.
There's a lot of repetitive listening
in the early stages in order to, you
know, to get a hold of the new language.
So in that second stage, all of a sudden
what we have been listening to, even
though we don't really understand it
all that well, it's becoming familiar.
We're going to, we're going back to
something that's no longer brand new.
In fact, it's familiar.
Still we understand 10, 15%.
It seems like there's an endless number
of words to learn, but it's a familiar.
And, and I enjoy that challenge when
I'm starting to get a bit of a sense
of the language and it's familiar,
familiar sounds, listening to the
same sounds that I don't understand,
struggling with the same writing
system that still presents challenges,
uh, but it's a familiar environment.
I, I miss it when I'm away from it.
I enjoy going back to it, even as the
language remains very unclear for me, I
enjoy that second period as we're starting
to turn the corner in the language.
Now, the third period, which is kind
of that long plateau, which for some
people can be a period of frustration.
For me, it's, it's not a period of
frustration because I'm now in a
situation where I understand, depending
on the content, you know, 20, 30,
40, 50% of some content, if I go back
to some of my earlier, sort of, mini
stories in LingQ where I've heard them
so many times, I understand 70%, 80%.
And every time I listen, I pick up
something new of my old beginner
material, and then I push myself forward
into new and more difficult material.
And, and I'm starting to feel that
I am going to be able to understand
that language, even though the
language still is a bit opaque.
It's still not really comprehensible,
but I recognize that I understand a
lot more than I understood before.
I almost feel as if I shouldn't
understand it, but I don't fully, I
understand some words, but I can't
get a sense of the whole meaning.
But still it's enjoyable because
I sense that I'm on the verge of
reaching, you know, a level of,
of comfortable comprehension.
I'm not there yet, but I
think I'm gonna get there.
So that sort of plateau period, which
is quite long, it seems there's an
endless number of words to learn.
It doesn't bother me 'cause I know
that if I continue with my good
language learning habits, if I continue
listening and reading, just as I've
already progressed from where I was
before, I will continue to progress.
The brain is getting used to the language.
The brain is already much more
used to the language than it
was in the previous stages.
Now the fourth stage, which is in
many cases, you know, as far as
people go, it's as far as I have
gone in a number of my languages.
It's where I understand 80% of most,
uh, language content, uh, of movies.
It can vary, but let's say
60, 70, 80%, I understand.
I'm comfortable if I'm in a
conversation with someone.
I can hold up my end of the conversation,
I understand what the person is saying.
I'm able to get my meaning across.
Sometimes, you know, with mistakes or
sometimes I can't remember words, and
sometimes I don't understand some of the
things that are said to me, but by and
large, I am functional in the language.
I meant B2, call it almost B2.
I'm functional, and if I leave
the language there, I've got
something that I can come back to.
So that's a sense of, you know,
achievement accomplishment.
It's, it's for, in many languages,
it's the end of the line.
I made it.
If I leave it and let it slide into
disuse, if again, I'm in a situation
where I need it, I can bring it back.
So I can tick it off.
This is a language that I have learned.
That doesn't mean I'm
perfect, but I've learned it.
So that's stage four of enjoyment.
Now, stage five, which is the
ultimate, is when you are totally
comfortable in the language.
You understand the movies.
You can be in any situation at any time.
You cannot speak the language for
two years and you come back to
it and you're just about where
you were when you left off.
Uh, this is like, I call it a C1.
This is where I feel, you know,
and I can listen to literature,
I can read literature, I can do
whatever I want in the language.
That is sort of the ultimate.
Now you don't have to achieve
that in the language in order to
enjoy the process of learning the
language or to enjoy the language.
I enjoy the language at the beginning.
If I start another language, uh,
might be Hindi or something, I'm
gonna enjoy that initial period of
discovery, then I'm gonna enjoy that
second stage when it's familiar.
It's a familiar struggle, but
it's a familiar environment.
I don't mind that.
I enjoy that.
Then when I'm on that long plateau,
where it seems as if I'm not progressing
and yet I'm understanding more and
more I feel as if I should understand.
I almost understand,
but I don't understand.
Uh, but then the fourth stage is
when I'm kind of at, almost at
the final stage of my journey.
I'm comfortable, I'm
happy I can tick it off.
It's mine.
But then with some languages, if I
get the opportunity, I'll push myself
through to that final stage of enjoy...
enjoyment.
But all stages are enjoyable.
And enjoying the language learning
process is not only the key to success,
but it also should be the goal.
So thank you for listening, and if
you enjoy my, uh, enjoy my videos,
please um, you know, subscribe.
And I'll leave you with, uh, a
couple of videos that I've done
on a similar subject in the past.
Bye for now.